you
hi everyone is cheering I'm on Ches calm
right now and I just got done going
through several tactics training puzzles
and I'd like to share three of them with
you they're all endgame puzzles each of
them it's white to move and I'm just
going to throw it to you and see if you
can solve that I'll go ahead and share
the solution with each of these three
and some of the thoughts I had when
trying to solve them myself
so in this first one it's white to move
if you'd like to go ahead and pause the
video see if you can find the best
continuation for white okay
the solution to this one is to
immediately push the a6 pawn and if
black continues to push what ends up
happening is white promotes first black
on the very next move promotes and now
we have a knight move with check which
is unleashing an attack against the
Queen we win the Queen in the game the
other variation is surprisingly enough
mmm the same tactic but with a different
pawn promoting after a six black seeing
that this quick race of the promotion of
the a pawn and the H fun won't work well
black might go ahead and grab the pawn
but that's okay we still have a jeep on
and similarly white will promote first
black will promote on the very next move
and we can force through this Queen a
eight move push the King back to its
initial position on b5 and once again
revisit this same tactic so whether it's
the apon promoting or the jeep on
promoting I thought that that was pretty
neat that you can force a queen a eight
move and then the follow-up and Knight
check picking up the Queen on each one
let's have a look at the second one
white to move
if you'd like to go ahead pause the
video see if you can find the best
continuation for white okay this one is
certainly an endgame study the only way
to try and draw this and as why you
should be looking to draw because
there's no way to stop f2
if you're not stopping f2 you're not
stopping black from promoting so white
has to come up with something clever
and this usually involves some steel
matrix the first move must be in g4 if
white doesn't play g4 black and push g4
and there's no way to disrupt the Kings
position on h5 there's no way to seal
him in in any way g4 must be the start
forcing King age six and the type of
reasoning you have to use at this point
is to know if given a move if the black
King can get to h7 he'll be okay so what
you must play here is white is King to
g8 you have to stop King age seven and
this at least threatens some stuff if we
can get the bishop on f8 or g7 that will
actually be mate
so this is a key move after G for King
age six you have to go King g8 to stop
King age seven
now black pushes we get the bishop here
we don't we don't just go to any square
the key idea is to go to d8 and now
making use of a stalemate trick Bishop
f6 the trick here Queen takes bishop
that's game over that's a stalemate now
this is what I calculated when trying to
do this puzzle but what I didn't take
into account was that there was an
additional move for black here and that
is to give this check so I wonder if any
of you came up with this other idea and
that black has in this position and that
is to give a check on C for King h8 and
now Queen f7 what are we doing now is
white well we can still draw by playing
Bishop takes g5 that's a check King
takes bishop is forced and this is yet
another instance of stalemate so I
thought that that was pretty cool I
didn't see this one again in its
entirety I only took it as far as well
you're only able to stop this
checkmating idea by taking the bishop
and it's stalemate I overlooked that
there was Queen f4 into f7 but even so
again we have another stalemate idea
with Bishop takes g5 certainly in
game study there and I think also one
more in-game study for the third and
final puzzle let's have a look at it
I'm pretty sure that this one is an
endgame study too so it's white to move
if you'd like to go ahead pause the
video what's the best continuation for
white
okay the solution here well before I
share the solution let me show you share
with you one of the thoughts I had in
how I came to the solution to this one
white just to keep things straight here
white is going up the board just two
squares away from promoting if black is
able to successfully get behind the pawn
this is what I concluded if the rook can
get behind the pond get to h3 and be
maintained on h3 there's not going to be
a win here for white so I then tried to
come up with ways to prevent this and I
also noticed that the black King is on
the edge and there is a possibility for
a mate trick King to c4 in other words
would be threatening rook a6 mate that
is in fact the correct start to this
puzzle King to c4 what's wrong with h7
the route gets behind and there's just
not a good follow up I mean what do you
do this pawn is under fire you could
protect them this pawn runs and yeah
you're not getting anywhere with this
approach white isn't getting anywhere
with pushing the pond so it must be
first King to c4 now what exactly is the
idea here
well what can black do
to disrupt this may threat give a check
we just take the rook he has two options
King a five King a three and you need to
understand both what to do in both cases
let's have a look first at King a three
now we push and what's the trick here
now once the ricketts behind the pawn
notice the king and the rook around the
same rank tactically vulnerable a fork a
deflection rook takes rook and now we
push through in one other clever
sequence and in fact the one that the
computer played out when I did the
puzzle and that is after this initial
move King c4 what do you do on King a5
well you give a check and now rook h5
that's a cool move pawn takes rook I
mean you're just ready to push through
on pawn takes rook we push and there's
no stopping this pawn from promoting
white goes on to win so I thought that
that one was pretty cool very simplified
position rook and pawn ending endgame
and we have these this combined idea
both King c4 threatening mate and the
two different ideas King a3 pushed
through with a fork or if King to a5 we
have a check and then we disrupt the
rooks ability to get behind the pawn and
track it down on takes we pushed through
and the rook is in an awkward spot the F
pawns in its way and the Aged han will
push through so I thought that those
were a few cool puzzles feel free to
share how you did with them in the
comment section below and I will catch
you in the next video that's all for now
take care bye